Cyprus and Israel have agreed to set up
a maritime Aid Corridor to Gaza the
announcement follows a meeting between
the Israeli foreign minister and his
surate counterpart in lanica alzer's
Laura Khan is in rala in the occupied
West Bank with the
details the two of them visited lanica
which is in the south of um Cyprus where
they went to um a port and they met with
a a joint um task Squad essentially
where they were looking at the
initiative and the logistics around the
initiative of creating a maritime route
of Aid to Gaza so um there is um a Joint
Forces looking at this over the next two
days uh now this initiative isn't new um
it has been um presented a couple of
times um once to the Paris peace Forum
last week uh where the cypriot president
and essentially gave them a 25 uh page
initiative uh that would look at a joint
um task Squad with um other countries
from around the world um in sending
these very large shipments from Cyprus
over to Gaza for the desperately needed
humanitarian Aid there uh now there was
much support from EU officials there uh
but some of them were concerned about
the many hurdles that they may face uh
one of which is how they can safely get
it into Gaza um you know they they were
afraid that the ship shipments could be
attacked on the way and also once it
it's at Gaza the entire point of these
shipments is they're much larger uh than
the trucks going in through the south of
Gaza at the moment uh but there's very
little uh in terms of infrastructure in
these ports so they have very small
ports so there's there's a mountain of
logistics to get through but Cyprus says
you know it is the country to do this
because they are the closest EU Nation
uh to Gaza so they said they they are
the natur
country to essentially help out and
Israel says they want to get this
initiative underway as soon as possible